I'm running a web design agency in
Singapore called bitmask and we built
websites with Django and Python we have
been doing this for the last four or
five years and yeah so the last six
months or so I was building a mobile app
for one of our biggest clients and we
were using react.js for this app and
that means I had to use a lot of
JavaScript I created a little repository
on github that shows it's basically it's
supposed to be a step-by-step guide that
teaches you how you can set up django
and then how you can create your first
few react components and use them in
your django application so the first
step is simply creating a Django project
and all you need to do for that is
actually one through these four commands
you could probably even skip the first
one if you don't care about virtual
environments so pip is a software that
comes with Python to install Python
packages so in the Python package that
we need to install it's called Django
once we have that installed we have
another command available on the
terminal which is called Django admin
and this command has a sub command
called start project and then we give
our project a name so I just call this
like Django react eg I react this is the
name of our Django project okay and what
this command here does is it creates a
DJ react folder on your hard drive which
already has a few files inside that come
that Django automatically generates for
you is like the minimum amount of files
that you need in order to run a Django
project and the last command here is not
necessary really but I like to rename
the DJ react folder into Django because
of the Django project so what you will
end up with is something like this the
Django folder which has managed to pie
file and the DJ react folder and inside
of that folder you will have the very
important file settings pie I will I
will talk about this file a lot today so
try to remember this URL spy and this
file we can ignore
so I explained a few other things like
if you install something this pip you
should also create a requirement stop
text file and put this same requirement
into that file so when you look into
this file it looks like this that's just
Django inside the latest version that's
just best practice it's not really
relevant to this project
mmm no when you need to do something I
will tell you it's after after we stop
the recording basically so after you ran
basically these two commands here you
should be able in your terminal to do
manage my run server I already have it
running actually yeah you should be able
to do manage pi run server and then in
your browser you can go to localhost and
you will see the Jango welcome website
that's basically the if you didn't do
anything this is what Jango will look
like it will show your welcome screen
just to tell you that just your settings
settings file is correct and that
everything worked okay so that's the
first step just installing Jango and
creating a project super easy and as a
second step I basically want to create a
view so that we can see like a hello
world text in our browser so this is
supposed to be our old django app right
we I built this because I want to
enhance my old django apps and used
react.js component instead of normal
django HTML code okay so in order to
hook up a view and django you need to go
into the URL spy file and you need to
add this line here and i actually add a
two views for demonstration purposes so
this basically says that at the URL view
to slash we should show this template
and at no URL at all so basically the
home page we should show this template
okay then you need to add a setting that
tells django where can find the
templates and then you need to create
the actual templates so those of you who
have already written HTML should be
familiar with this basically we will
have a base HTML file
and then the to template files for the
two different views so Django has this
cool thing that is called template
inheritance that means I mean usually
when you build an HTML site
they always need all this boilerplate
code here right every HTML website needs
to have an HTML tag head tag a body tag
and so on and but for our views we don't
really want to repeat all this every
single time so that's why we can put
this into one central file and then the
sub files for the for each view they
will extend the central file ok so that
basically means everything that's in
between the block main here which is
just a tag that says view 1 should be
rendered in the base HTML file in here
so this part will be replaced with this
part ok so if you look at the code again
so that you can visualize how it looks
on the file system basically what we did
in this step is we created the templates
folder and the three files that I just
showed right so when you when you go
into the file you can see it's just this
template file with the block and the
other two files they extend the base
file and they fill in some content into
the block ok and that's the step when
you did this and you run in your
terminal
you run manage pie run server
you will see view 1 which is the thing
that we put in view 1 HTML in the file
right or if we go to the other URL view
- we will see vo - okay so this should
already if you have never done web
development and you want to get into it
and you thought that Django might be a
good technology this should get your
excited it's like well I just have to
create a few templates I put something
into the URLs dot PI file and I can see
something in the browser right and from
here you could start actually writing
you're making your website beautiful add
more content and then afterwards you
will get that you will ask yourself hmm
how can I have some more dynamic stuff
how can I save something into the
database and get out of the database so
from here onwards you will dig deeper
into the Dan Django documentation and
learn more about Django but which we
won't do today so the next step is the
one where people who want to use reactor
as often struggle or give up so this
took me I don't know maybe a few weeks
to get my webpack conflict nice and
correct and understand what's going on
like six months ago when I started using
react js4 for my project so
we wanted to build a mobile app and we
didn't want to use angularjs so there's
a software called Cordova that allows
you to write a mobile app but use web
technology and yeah I heard I just heard
about react.js and people are pretty
excited about it and said it's very very
fast
and it gives you a mobile gives it a
chance to build a mobile app that almost
feels native so that's why I thought I'd
just give it a try and turn out to
actually work and look really good
that's why I decided to use react I
guess in the first place and a few
months later Facebook released react
native and then we threw away my
react.js mobile app and we migrated
everything to react native which is a
very similar technology but it uses the
actual iOS and Android native views so
it feels even more native this is really
cool technology but it uses almost the
same code as that that we had already
built so the migration was actually very
painless so this is the most difficult
step here the problem is with react you
you've write your front end using
javascript okay and usually you will
have one javascript file which is the so
called entry point into your app and
from there you import a lot of other
smaller files and you use them and
inside of those smaller files you might
import even more small smaller
components and it's all JavaScript code
okay and but the problem is the browser
doesn't really know about how to do
imports and all these kind of things the
browser really just wants to have the
browser says give me one component J s
file that I can load and then I try to
execute that file right we cannot give a
lot of files to the browser and expect
the browser to execute those files
correctly so what we need to do is we
need to bundle our whole app into one
big JavaScript file that includes
everything and then we can put this file
on a content delivery network or
wherever we host our static files for
our website and make sure that the
browser can download this file and
execute it so this is what the software
called web pack is all about it asks you
where is your entry point into your
education and where should I save the
bundle and then it goes into your files
and and gobbles them all up and tries to
put them into one big file okay
the problem is
yeah so usually when you develop like
this with react yes you want to do
something that is called hot reloading
so that means you see your work in your
browser and you are working in your
editor and every time you're safe
your browser gets updated okay so that
means that kind of web peg generates a
new bundle on the fly but it doesn't
really save it to the database but it
keeps it in memory and there's a tricky
magical way how web pick can communicate
with your browser and set and tell the
browser that the bundle has just been
updated and then the browser will
refresh itself and there's a django
application called
django web web pack loader which has
only one purpose it it tries to teach
django what is the current file name of
your latest bundle okay we will see that
later when we actually generate a manual
you will see that the file names they
always have a random string at the end
so every time we save and we change our
code the finite file name of the final
bundle changes as well and that's a
problem with Django because usually when
you just woke up let's say jQuery minge
is it's always this file name
Django always knows that this is the
file I have to download and execute but
with our own bundles we will always have
these random strings at the end so the
bra Django needs to be up-to-date and
know what is our latest file that we
have saved
I could configure webpack in a way that
it always says the files was exactly the
same name but it's usually not not a
good idea because then when your user
refreshes the browser like the user
comes back to your website the next day
then the old file has been cached by its
brought by the browser so the browser
sees like fjs alright I don't know that
this last week already so I will use it
again so then the user will be using an
outdated version of your app right but
by just changing the file name every
time the browser will think that this is
a new new static asset that it needs to
download again and then you never have
these problems that users have outdated
or running outdated code yeah so anyways
in order to use a third-party django
application we need to install it same
way like we install django so we run pip
install django a peg loader and then
most third-party django apps are used in
the same way you add them to your
settings pi file remember i said this is
the super important general settings
file so we add one line to that file
here and then we add a few more lines
further down the file telling django
where we are saving our static assets so
static assets is like javascript files
CSS files images that should be
displayed on the website these are
considered static assets okay the mmm
okay and then we need this crazy
scary-looking package JSON file this
basically is the same like the
requirements not text file that we use
in Python so it's also just a file that
tells your project what kind of software
needs to be installed so that this
project works and we basically just put
in package names here and the version
numbers that we want to have all right
you remember when I showed you the
requirements text file it only had one
line Jango equals equals one point nine
point zero point three so that's the
Django package for Python that we want
to install and here's the same we want
to install a JavaScript package called
babel and it's dis version and a lot
more Java Script packages so but let's
just ignore them for now
so the config that we need to generate
for for web pack is looks kind of scary
at first because
I split up into two files it's gonna be
a base config and then further down we
have a second file which is which has
almost the same name but there's local
in here okay this will make more sense
later when I talk about deployment
because usually in the real world you
have your own computer you have a
staging server and you have a production
server okay and you need to generate
three different versions of your app for
the three different environments because
for example when you develop locally
your API might have this address
localhost 8080 I version one right but
on your staging server it might be this
address sandbox my app comm API version
1 and on the production server it's just
my accom so you have if the website is
basically running on three different
machines your own machine the staging
machine the production machine and that
means that your app that the which is in
the JavaScript bundle right needs to
know to which API am I talking to right
now so these kind of things have to be
hard-coded into the app and so that that
is the reason why we need three
different config files okay but most of
the config files is exactly the same for
all three environments so that's why we
have a base config file which has most
of the stuff and then we have specific
config files for the other environments
which overwrite a few things that need
to change for that environment okay so
let's just have a quick look at the base
config file this module exports thing
here is a JavaScript thing that means
that down here we can import that config
file so if you have done a little bit of
Python already you know that you can do
this from django import models right you
can in your Python files you can import
other PI's and modules and this is the
same in JavaScript here but it looks
mean the syntax was a little bit
different it basically says that we want
to import this javascript file and we
want to put it into this variable name
okay and then the question
what will actually end up in this
variable name and it will be the thing
that this file here exports okay and
what does it export it exports something
that looks very much like a Python
dictionary
you know the Python has dictionaries
with curly brackets and it has lists
with square brackets right so JavaScript
basically has the same thing I think in
JavaScript this is not called
dictionaries probably I don't know it's
called object I guess right Mike yeah
so we are basically creating an object
that has several attributes so context
was one attribute entry as one attribute
output is one attribute and each
attribute has certain values and the
important one here is the entry point
right we are telling webpack where is
the JavaScript file where my react is
application begins you will notice that
there is no js' ending here you can
leave out the ending because you are
free to put to name it J s or JSX
or in any way actually so by leaving out
the ending webpack we'll be able to just
find the file that's called f1 dot
anything and assume that this is your
entry file ok we will ignore this for
now and then this output path is
important so this tells webpack where
the final bundle file should be saved on
your hard drive
ok so ok maybe I should talk about this
vendors thing here the problem is react
native is like jQuery it's a pretty big
library
it's I don't know maybe 180 kilobytes or
even even more so and it will never
really change as long as Facebook
doesn't release a new version of
react.js this library will not change so
it would be cool if your browser can
download this big library and cache it
so the next time when the user comes
back this was already in cache and
doesn't need to be redone loaded again
but the stuff that changes all the time
which is our own app right this should
be in a different file so by using this
commons chance plugin here and by saying
that react should be
entry-point webpack will generate to
bundle files it will generate one super
big bundle file that contains react.js
and everything is related to react yes
and it will con create one small bundle
file which only contains our own code
that we have actually written which in
comparison to react is tiny right and
yeah so that's that's the purpose of the
comments chain plug-in did the rest we
can ignore for now so that's the base
config okay the local config
I okay so the local config first of all
that imports the base config into the
variable name config and then it
overrides a few of the attributes so you
up here you can see that we define the
plac plugins attribute and it's a list
of plugins okay so down here we are
overriding the plugins attribute and we
are adding we are concatenating some
elements to that list so basically we
are saying in general we want to use the
commas chunk plug-in but if we are
developing on our local machines we want
to add the bundle tracker plug-in all
right and we'll explain what the bundle
tracker plug-in does later so if you
would run webpack now it will probably
crash and give you some syntax errors
that's because there is a new version of
JavaScript emerging called es 2015 and
this has a lot of things that for
example it has classes it has this kind
of way of importing things so this loss
you know this is still JavaScript down
here here it looks much more like pison
already write import something from
something when you compare to this this
is also just an import but it looks
completely different because this is
written in the old way and this is
written in the new way and in order to
be to teach web pack that it's it's
should be able to deal with the new way
you need to create this bubble our C
file and put these settings inside this
is also a pitfall like when you want to
get into react.js development you do
everything like they describe it in the
tutorial but most tutorials don't tell
you about this because most people have
this file in their home folder and they
forgot about it that they had to set
this up this file a few months ago and
for them everything just works but when
you try to reproduce it
nothing works at all because you don't
have this file yet so yeah you need to
copy and paste this into this file so
now we will basically have configured
web pack correctly but we don't have any
JavaScript code yet that web pack can
run so that means we need to create an
app one dot JSX file which
supposed to be our entry point right and
in this file this is actually how
react.js looks like and we will talk
about this later so for the purpose of
this step here we just want to be able
that we can compile something and see
something in the browser so we create
one component here and this component
uses another component that I'm also
importing here so that means we have to
create a file for that other component
as well and implement that component as
well right and for like demonstration
purposes I went even further so this
file is using another component called
headline which I'm importing here right
so we need a third file which is another
react component so you will already see
a pattern when you look at these
components you always see that there's a
class it has the same name as the file
name that's a good convention and it
extends reactor component and you have
to import react here so that's why
reactors available here okay and inside
of that class we are defining functions
very similar to Python classes and the
most important function is called render
and it's supposed to return something
and what it should return is basically
something that looks like HTML code
right you you are you have seen this h1
tag here and here we there is some magic
happening there's some variable stuff
inside the HTML and the interesting
thing is when and here's the same right
for the headline for the headline
component we have a class called
headline which is the same as the file
name the class has a render function and
the render function returns some HTML
and the interesting thing is when you go
one step for one step up the headline
component can now be used as if it is an
HTML tag as well okay so that so when
you build react applications you are
actually trying to build a lot of very
small components that do one thing and
one thing really well so basically my
headline component will have the correct
color the color correct font size the
correct font family and all these things
so that and then everywhere in my code I
just use headline and I
be sure that all my headlines look
exactly the same okay and if somebody
says all right we have a new style guide
for our company and all the headlines
need to be green now you just need to
change something in this single file
here
right okay so yeah no the before code is
using whatever was before es2015
I don't know how it's called JavaScript
old JavaScript I don't know actually I
don't know I don't know if I would be
able to use I would probably not be able
to use it for executing web pack I'm not
sure Mike do you know basically whenever
I look into tutorials and other
boilerplate repositories they are all
using the old syntax for the backpack
config so I just copy and pasted that to
be honest maybe you can try it you can
try to replace this with the new
sentence but I guess it would not work
most of the tutorial never tell you
about that paper I see and we also don't
know what is the tutorial will work
using this one
yeah so you mean for now he just now the
system to use es 2 1 exactly
so how it looks like on the file system
is in your Django folder we will now
have this babel our c file and whenever
you execute your web pack it will try to
look if this file exists and it will use
it I mean it's probably only half the
truth actually web pack is using some
code it's using something called bubble
and bubble is the one that is looking
for the bubble our C file I think that's
the point when we execute web app web
pack we are not using bubble yet but web
pack is the software that invokes bubble
so while we are executing web pack this
file is not being used and that's why I
think the new centers will not use when
you execute member but I might be wrong
that's not discussed this in great
length because I don't want to tell
wrong things and end up on YouTube like
that so so basically you know we created
the base config file and we created the
local config file right which uses most
of the parts of the base config and we
created a react J's folder which has our
entry point which is this first
component here right and we created a
containers folder I will explain maybe I
will explain later why I split this up
into two different components which has
another react component and we have our
components folder which has the mini
small headline component ok so you can
see actually reactions is not that scary
the mini smallest component is just 5
lines of code and it's relatively easy
to understand what it does ok and when
you and that's what they say on the
Facebook website give it five minutes
they're like if you try to mess around
with this you will fall in love with it
and then you will dig deeper and learn
all the difficult parts they don't tell
you that it's actually very difficult to
understand they just tell you
look it's so easy it's just five lines
of code give it five minutes and then
you walk down the rabbit hole and you
don't find the way back anymore okay and
you end up becoming a JavaScript
developer and you are actually a Python
developer
right so this was step three and
hopefully when we run this what what
happened oh right it still looks the
same right because so far we have only
created a lot of boilerplate code config
files components all this stuff and we
have even created a bundle like this
last command here and my tutorial will
teach you how to actually create a
bundle but in our browser we can still
see the old view one right that's
because in our Django template we
haven't made any changes we should now
include the new JavaScript bundle that
we have created in our Django template
and that's the thing where most people
that use Django didn't really know so
far how to do it nicely so let's see how
that works so if you go back to your
view one dot HTML you remember that
there was only one tag here basically
saying to render view one right this is
this view one here now we put something
different here now we put an empty div
container here which an ID called m1
alright and we this is something
specific to Django because we are using
the web Django web page load a
third-party app which we have installed
using pip before we are now able to load
a so-called Django template tag and the
template tag is called random bundle and
we can use this template tag to load
specific JavaScript bundles with certain
names and when you remember back to your
to our web pack config and we had two
entry points the first entry point was
called f1 and the second entry point was
called vendors okay so those are exactly
the same two names that we will use here
in the Django template right and what
web pack django web pack loader actually
just does is it teaches django
which name here corresponds to which
bundle file on the file system that we
hopefully have generated if we didn't
generate it then it will crash and say
that the file cannot be found ok so
basically when the server returns this
template it's gonna be an empty website
of just a white empty page which has to
load this JavaScript stuff here first
and once this stuff is loaded then it
will replace this emptiness in between
the diff here with our actual JavaScript
react components and then we will see
whatever the components output okay oh
yeah there's a final thing that you need
to put into your Django settings so that
web page load R knows in which folder
the bundle files will end up and where
it can find these WebP X that's JSON
file so I haven't really explained what
these do the thing is every time you run
web pack because we are using the bundle
tracker plug-in in our local web pack
config it generates this file here and
the file basically only says that the
app was the name app one has its bundle
file called like this and this is the
random string I was talking about this
one changes every time you save the file
right and it also tells Django where
this bundle can be found on the hard
drive okay so Django basically only
knows this file and because of that file
Django knows when I say render bundle
app 1 it knows which javascript file to
import ok
yes so if we do all this and so this is
Steph all right yeah this is step one
and we run manage pie run server and we
go to the browser now we see something
new which is the same let's have a look
at our JavaScript components
hey let's internet so slow
here see I was using the headline
component with the text something new
inside so we can we can confirm we are
no longer seeing some old Django
templates UML stuff we are now seeing
the output the result of our react.js
application okay all right
so but so far this is still very
inconvenient because every time you're
safe you also need to run webpack to
generate a new bundle and then you need
to refresh your browser to see the
result
that's too much clicking around and
typing in the terminal so we need a way
to make this automatic first of all we
need a new file called server GIS this
is another scary thing that where many
people give up and we need to copy and
paste this whole code inside I won't
even talk about what this does is
basically it's a web server programmed
in JavaScript and we will use nodejs to
execute this web server this server will
listen on port 3000 and do magical
things we will see that later and in
order for this to work we need to make a
little update to our web page local
config and so this was our entry file
here we need to add these two lines ok
and we need to add this line which
didn't exist before and we need to add
these two new plackets before we only
had the bundle tracker plug-in but when
we want to do web pack when we want to
do hot reloading with web pack we need
to add these two plugins as well so I
mean I don't even understand what all
this means I just copy and paste this
from some tutorial try it it works oh
it's great never touch it again and and
don't worry about it right so if you
have all this in place and this is step
5
you can do manage my run server you can
go to a website and oh my god
I see nothing this is because I forgot
that I also need to run note server dot
J's so when you want to develop your
site now you have to remember always to
execute both servers the Django web
server and the note web server okay when
you do that now our app is rendered
again okay and now look at this this is
the cool thing when we save our code
let's say we change this - oh my god
works and save oh my god it works see
let's save it changes immediately
correct when I save I press save now
and there's the change okay so this is
the hot reloading that's going on and
it's basically recreating the bundle and
keeping it in memory so Django is no no
longer looking onto the hard drive for
the bundle it's now looking to this port
3000 webserver so it's trying to fetch
it from I don't know where it comes from
from memory I guess and this is really
powerful this enables you like if you
have for example in your office you have
a to monitor setup you have the website
here you have your editor here and your
code encoding code and like creating
beautiful user interfaces is really
really good with this because you can
try like make it 1 pixel bigger one
pixel smaller a little bit more to the
left to the right and it's like so fast
it really encourages you to experiment
and come up with new ideas and try
different versions ok so this is a great
way to build websites
[Music]
so
yeah many people already got to that
that far and then the next question is
okay but how do I deploy my stuff to my
Jango to my already existing Jango
infrastructure to my servers okay
and as I already explained in the
beginning what the only thing we need to
do is we will create two more web pack
convicts one is called stage config yes
and the other one is called trot convict
j/s and those convicts same as the local
one they import the base config and they
change a few of the of the variables
here for example they say that we will
have a specific folder for our bundles
which is called bundles slash stage and
we will also have a specific folder for
production bundles and for example this
plug-in here the define plug-in
basically allows you to set something
called like something like environment
variables that you can use in your
JavaScript code so this enables you to
have things like if environment is
production then use this API URL
otherwise use that or if environment
equals local then do some special
debugging output that you don't really
want to use if for the for the real
production website all these kind of
things or for example I like to describe
my API base URLs in here so they if I if
I run web pack with this config all my
API calls will go against this URL if I
run it with this production config all
my API calls will go against a different
URL okay so that means every time when
we want to release a new version so this
has been this is how you call web pack
this is the command and then you
basically say I want to run web pack
with this config okay and so that means
when I made some changes to my app and
I'm ready to test it I have to create
two new sets of bundles one for the
staging server and one for the
production server assuming that it's
fine and I after I tested it on staging
I want to have the same stuff on the
nationís
so that is a lot of stuff to type in the
terminal right I have to every time I
have to create these two outputs here so
that's why I use something called fabric
it's a very powerful and helpful package
in pison so we would use pip install
fabric and we will create a so-called
fat file in our root directory and we
will put this little bit of code into
the fat file which basically only says
that we have a fabric task task which is
called webpack and whenever we run fat
web pack on the terminal it should
execute these four terminal commands
okay so maybe you have already heard
about make files maybe when you compile
source code on Linux or whatever you
often have to deal with make files so
this is a similar thing like make files
so let me show this to you and step six
okay
when you do fat webpack it does all
these things it's just one command but
it's executing four different commands
it it deletes the already existing
bundles from your last time and it
generates two new bundles for staging
and for production and puts them in the
same folder again okay so when I run git
status now I can see that a lot of files
have changed right some files have been
deleted and there are new files that
haven't existed before because they all
have different file names right that's
why I want to delete them because if I
only save new ones I will I will end up
having a hundred thousand bundle files
half a year from now and yeah no need to
version to put them into version control
all of them so yeah for those this might
be may be interesting for people who
watch it on YouTube who know Django
already my development workflow is like
this I go into my project folder
I run managed by run server and note
server J s so that I can see my stuff in
the browser I start coding my app when
I'm done I commit my changes and then I
run fat web pack to generate the bundles
and usually I like to have a different
commit only for the bundles and then
finally I run my deployment script from
a Django website and that's the cool
thing that means you you are now using
react.js but you don't really have to
make any changes to your infrastructure
the the way how you deploy Django stays
exactly the same
however I mean every company does it in
a slightly different way so it doesn't
interfere with that at all right so you
only make sure that you generate your
bundles commit them into your repository
and run a normal deployment okay I have
three more steps which is probably a bit
difficult for you guys now but might be
interesting for the video so I try to
keep this a bit faster I won't I don't
know should I explain everything in
detail the more I explain the last time
we will have to try it on the laptops
later so I have to find a good middle
way anyway so yeah quickly okay so the
thing with with react components is they
have something called props and state
basically when you think about the
component for example this this headline
component that we had right
it's supposed to render something that
has been passed into the component and
so the component basically doesn't
really know what kind of text it should
render you can put any kind of text
inside and the component will render
that text so that it's some information
that has been given into the component
from the outside okay
and this works for for small components
that only deal with themselves but what
if you have for example a button
component and when you click at that
button some kind of counter on your
website should increase and the counter
is a different component so these two
components they don't know about each
other necessary they don't necessarily
know about each other
so how that's the counter know that it
should increase when somebody clicks at
the button right so we need some kind of
event system like the button when you
click it needs to emit some kind of
event like I have been clicked and the
counter needs some kind of event
listening system so that when the
counter will listen to I have been
clicked and when he hears when the
counter hears that event he will
increase in itself for example okay so
if you read about react you will quickly
learn about something called flux that's
like a way of thinking how you can
manage your state and react applications
and there are a lot of a lot of
different flux implementations so it's
basically another JavaScript library
that you need to import in your project
and then you need to understand the
documentation of that library and then
you can use it the question is which one
of those that exists should you use
there are like ten difference once maybe
I mean three months ago was 10 different
now it's probably 20 different and but
thankfully some smart person came along
and invented something called Redux and
it's a little bit like flux but I think
it's easier to understand than flux and
less complicated what you need to do in
order to use Redux is first you need to
create a so-called action creator ok you
will put that into a file for example
called counteractions JSX George is
owned that's a typo you need to fix that
and basically what we do is we create a
constant which describes the name of the
actions so let's let's assume there's a
button you click that button then the
action increase should be emitted ok and
so Redux this will make more sense later
when we look at the next file by
definition all the the actions should
have this look that there should be
JavaScript objects or if you think about
pison there should be dictionaries and
they should have a key called type and
the type should be some some string
actually and you know this constant here
is a string okay so this is a bit
confusing so let's maybe let's not get
the next file so what you should keep in
mind is the action creators describe
what kind of actions can happen ok then
we need something else that's called a
reducer and we will put that into a
folder called reducers and we call it
counters on J as for example the
reducers always look like this they
import the action creators that belong
to this reducer and they describe how
the data looks like usually when you are
working with some more complex database
for example I don't know
you have a user profile then maybe you
would have user profile here right or
let'slet's when you think about Facebook
maybe they have user profile here and
then they have posts for your timeline
and this is another key and this
dictionary here so basically here you
describe how the data looks like that
this reducer takes care of and we just
want to increase the clicks in a counter
so that's why I'm only having one
variable here called clicks and I
initiate it with zero okay and this is
the actual reducer function here it's
basically just a function any name name
doesn't matter
and into the function we put some state
the and at the very beginning we put in
the initial state and every time when an
action happens so when this increase
action here is fired it will be put here
as the action variable into the entry
into the reducer function and with it
the last state will put will be put into
the function so you can think about it
let's say let's say we click at the
button 20 times in a row that generates
20 actions that will be put into a queue
right and then slowly each item will
take will be taken out of the queue and
will be put into the reducer function so
that's the state it's the last state
right together with one of those 20
actions and then inside of this reducer
function we will manipulate the state so
we are this is a weird new JavaScript
syntax here so this does not mean this
is a dictionary don't get confused of
the because of the curly brackets this
means that we are taking the old state
variable and we are returning a copy of
it and we are only changing the clicks
attribute to something new and we are
increasing it by one just try to like
this is basically what this statement
means it does it does a lot of stuff in
one line of code which would usually
take more lines of code that's the only
reason why we use this so it looks nicer
so you can think of the reducer like old
state gets we put the old state into the
function and we return a new manipulated
state a copy
we cannot manipulate
the actual stay we have to return a copy
okay and there and in order to get redux
working you need to remember our app m1
Dodgers X file it used to be a very
small component right now there's all
this stuff here in the file before the
component was only using the other sub
component and now we have to import all
this which is a Redux related and then
we have to add this code this is all for
because your app will usually have more
than just one reducer and it assembles
all the reducers that are available and
generates like one big store you can
think so the store has several reducers
remember we only have one reducer and
the reducer has called counters and it
only counts the clicks but if you have a
really complex application you might
have a lot of different producers like
maybe one reducer that only deals with
user profile data one reduce and it only
deals with your products if it's a
webshop one reducer that only deals with
I know comments if it's a block or
whatever right and you act might be
complex it might have a webshop and a
block and a user profile and and so on
and so on so that's why you want to have
your data capsulated
in in small reduce hopefully as small as
possible reducer files that's why you
split it up into several files and this
code basically makes sure to collect all
these files and generate one big store
out of it and then it wraps this around
our outermost component and then this
component is becomes more powerful it's
now listening to all the actions that
are happening and if some actions happen
that change the data the component will
rerender itself automatically that's
kind of the idea so when we go into the
so this is everyone is our outermost
component right and we were loading
another component here this one needs to
change a little bit we need to import
connect and put it on top of the class
as a decorator so this add symbol here
means
it's a decorator and we basically just
say that inside of our class we want to
be we want to have a variable called
counters so we made up this name here
counters I could name this in any way
and counters is the counters reducer
from our store right because we I said
that we we are assembling all the
reducers and there will be in this state
variable here so we could have stayed
toward user profile' state or product
state or whatever in our case we only
have one state or our counters and
obviously I just keep the same name and
then inside of my react application I
can now make use of this counters
variable okay it's no part of the
react.js properties this will confuse
you because you need to read the
react.js tutorial to understand what
properties and state means but basically
just think about it like this is a
bucket of variables that this react.js
component has access to and one of those
variables is called counters because we
connected it to our reducers okay so
yeah let's just try if this thing works
because it's always so much nicer when
when something happens on the screen
step 7 okay
so I run minish Pyro's over
so this is my button here and when I
click it increases another component
okay so refreshing it gets back to zero
exactly and that's a good point the last
set will deal with that like usually you
need to fetch your data from the
database so every time you load you
reload your app it refreshes the data
and displays the last the data it was
saved and database last here I'm just
initiating with zero and then we are
counting up from zero and next time when
you reload the application we are
initiating from zero again right all
right cool so that works there's two
more things styles so you all know a
little bit about HTML so that means you
also know a little bit about CSS
properly probably right
who knows about CSS okay so that's
almost the same people that also know
about HTML and this is something where
the community is in a heated debate
because react basically makes it very
easy to define your Styles right there
in JavaScript so you are no longer
writing CSS files no longer you will no
longer have central style sheets for
your application instead you can put
your Styles as a JavaScript object right
next to the component that's being
styled and this is really powerful
because I don't know maybe I'm a very
bad web designer but every single
project that I have ever done ended up
having a three thousand line style sheet
that nobody dares to touch like you are
usually only adding more stuff to the
stylesheet because you are scared to
delete anything because you never know
when your site has like your website has
300 pages and subpages and whatever you
never know if I delete this will
suddenly something on my website look
ugly and better don't touch it I mean
obviously there are people that are
only writing CSS and they are very good
at it and they know how to maintain the
CSS files properly but usually most of
the teams I've worked with they they
just accepted the fact that the CSS file
is a huge you know a huge mess and you
don't have this problem here anymore if
if you wonder you can I change this
color to red then you will just check
where is it used so this is the style
called counter and then it's being used
here so you look at this component here
and you know it's a relatively small
component and they are usually always
pretty small and it's a relatively small
chunk of java CSS code so you can the a
developer even a developer who doesn't
know the whole system who has just
joined your team and he has the task to
fix this one component the developer
will probably be able to make a good
decision if it's safe to change this to
red or not right so that means you will
have you actually have only JSS code in
your app that really matters and know
that CSS code that nobody uses anymore
okay yeah the center is different so you
cannot use dashes in here usually it's
font - size text - decoration and all
these things you have to use camel case
so called Kim okay so you start with a
small letter and then after when there
used to be a dash here this letter has
to be capital okay so and then and
there's another library called radium
actually there are a lot a lot of
different libraries for the react j/s
ecosystem that help you writing styles
right there in JavaScript and I just
happen to stumble upon radium when I
needed it and I stick to it so I don't
know if it's the best one but for me it
does everything that I need and so you
just need to import radium and then you
need to put another decorator around
your class here and that's all then you
can use style equals and this is some
weird new JSX syntax from Facebook so
you are saying that the style attribute
is going to be a variable so that's why
we put
curly brackets here and the variable is
supposed to be an array that's why there
are square brackets and the first
element of the array is the counter
style and then the counter style is here
all right so we can even put comma
separated more than just one style and
they will overwrite each other so that
way you can write a little bit more
modular code yeah I'm not going to show
this as basically only makes the counter
blue so it's not a big difference the
last part is so I mean this tutorial so
far if you do this at home you can
follow this you will end up at the same
stage and then you are like okay cool
now I know how to do Django I know how
to do react to yes I want to build the
next Facebook now and okay so how do I
get data right that's like the next
important question that you will
definitely ask yourself and and there's
actually a lot of work that you need to
do for this first of all so I'll rush
through this a little bit I created a
utility CAS file which basically okay so
now I have to go one step back um there
is a new standards coming up on how
browsers can do Ajax requests so if you
have used jQuery before there's the
jQuery AJAX function which allows you to
write JavaScript code that can like talk
to other websites and other web servers
and api's and there's something new
coming up because you might not you
might not be using jQuery if you use
reactions usually you will not use
jQuery anymore so how do you use how do
you do
Ajax requests now right so there is a a
new function coming up here called fetch
sometime in the in the future browsers
will just natively support this and
nodejs on the server will also support
this all right now nobody will need to
force it so you need to import another
library called isomorphic fetch which is
the so-called polyfill for your browser
and for nodejs
to make sure that this fetch function
here
work in your browser and on the server
so just accept it like sooner like like
maybe three years from now this line
will no longer be necessary necessary
hopefully and the fetch function is
returning oh God no need to go to
policies it returns the so-called
promise okay I'll not explain this
basically when you when you talk to a
server there are several things that can
happen first of all the response will be
successful right the server gets back to
your vessel response or the response
will be some kind of error message a
very common error message is 400 which
probably means that you send wrong data
and the server is saying I'm here I can
hear you but the stuff that you sent to
me doesn't make any sense so the server
will return with arrows there's another
very common error that can happen then a
500 internal server error you might have
seen that when you go to a website and
it's just wide and says internal server
error so any kind of a lot of it's not
just a 500 error a lot of different
errors can actually happen and finally
the fifth thing that wait how many is it
success five 400 error 500 error and
finally the fourth thing that can happen
is that you don't have an internet
connection so your request will end up
nowhere and timeout probably so I
basically just wrote a function the
function is called request it requests
it requires the URL you want to talk to
some additional options we are not using
the options here in these examples and
then for callback functions so this is
this is a weird thing that actually you
can do this was Pisan as well you can
write a function that accepts other
functions as parameters okay so we are
basically putting in four different
functions into this function and then we
are reacting to the different things so
if the fetch request returns we check
the status if it's 200 it's a success
that means we we turn the JSON response
into some JavaScript objects and
then we call this callback function here
okay and so if it's an error we call the
other callback function if it's a really
bad error we call the 500 callback
function or if it's a really really bad
error and then then the internet didn't
work we call the failure function so
this will make more sense when we look
at this here so this should look
familiar if you didn't fall asleep in
two steps ago
it's another action creator right we had
the we had an action creator for
counters which had these constants here
and you know the increase here we have
the four kinds of results that can
happen and we need another one to signal
that we have just started doing a fetch
right so these are the five things that
always happens when you talk to the
Internet you start talking to the
Internet and then either it works or in
lots of cases it doesn't work so that's
why we create five different actions
here okay and that's something that you
have to make up yourself
so I'm I didn't tell you that so I'm
trying to build extend our app so that
it fetches all my own github
repositories from github so that's why I
call this fetch repos repositories okay
so if you would write a function that's
supposed to fetch the user profile for
example then you would call it fetch
user profile and fetch user profile
success and so on you can make up the
name yourself something that describes
the thing that's supposed to fetch okay
and you might remember from the counters
action creator that it should return
something like this that has a type and
returns that the increase constant right
there's a second way that we can do we
can return a function instead that needs
to have the dispatch parameter this is
really difficult to explain even when I
look at this and I have used
like 100,000 times now I still have have
a hard time wrapping my head around this
so basically this basically tells redux
that we are trying to do an action here
that takes a lot of time because we
don't know when the result will come
back to us right when you talk to the
internet you don't know how long it
takes for the server to respond so this
is a so called asynchronous action
that's happening here
Sherry's giving up huh
don't give up Cheri almost there is the
last step and almost at the end of the
slide alright so yeah so I'm basically
first I'm dispatching the action that
tells my system that I'm going to talk
to the internet now right it's the first
one and then I call this request
function the one that I described above
that I have written here which allows
all these callback functions here right
so keep this in mind keep this function
definition in mind when we go down here
here we are using that function right
and these are the four callback
functions that the function definition
requires that we are passing into the
function the syntax might be a bit
confusing but this is some new
JavaScript syntax to create an anonymous
function on the fly so when you see
these brackets here with the fed arrow
that means that this line is a function
although it doesn't have this kind of
syntax where you really say this is a
function called so-and-so right this
basically means this is a function
without any name and it requires one
parameter and it it this is the code
inside the function okay so basically
you can see that we are having four
functions here and it's exactly these
four functions that our request function
requires okay all right and then we
would create a new reducer which which
has the repositories from github that
I'm trying to fetch
and a variable that says is it currently
loading or not okay and here you can see
that we are now listening to the
different actions that can happen for
example when we start fetching we change
our state and we say now it is loading
we set it to true alright and if it's
successful we say now it's no longer
loading and this is the result that we
got so we change repos to whatever is
attached to the action okay and in all
other cases we just say now it's no
longer loading but you know we still
have no repositories so that's the
reducer and then you need to make a lot
of changes here and there and here is
how we can change the react component
remember all the react components they
have this class and then they have the
render function and they are supposed to
return some kind something that looks
like HTML okay so this is exactly this
render function from our react component
and now here we can connect to our
reducer and we can say is it loading or
is it empty like we don't have any
repositories in that case we render a
loading screen otherwise we render a
real component okay and then but you can
dig through this if you do this at home
I created another component which takes
care of showing all the different
repositories that we fetch from the
internet and this component looks like
this it's basically using for each to
iterate over each component and then
render just a div with the component
name right so I mean this is too complex
to describe now and we need to get to
finish to wrap up this talk so this is
something if you look at this at home
you will probably understand it after a
while if you stare at it long enough but
let's just see what it does that's so
more so much more interesting
so step and a step
mr. Pires over
solid it shows loading and then when
github responds with my repositories
it's showing all my github repositories
it's the this is the same that you can
see when you go to my github profile
here or here
what repositories
hey repositories and see these are my
repositories here and we are now
fetching them because github actually
has an API you can go to API that github
calm I forgot the name it's probably
users oh yeah and then the user name and
then repos and it will return this lot
here which is a so-called JSON string
and here it is like Chen Tweep is one of
my repositories it has this ID and this
is the full name blah blah blah and
there's a few few extra information
about this repository so see Chantry
also shows up here in our react
application all right yes
okay so for the record to wrap this
recording up if you follow these steps
on this github repository here I have
actually basically everything that I
just told you it's also written down
here so you can go through this
step-by-step all the code you can just
copy and paste if you're not sure how
your folder structure should look like
just open this in another tab and
compare how your hard disk the files on
your hard disk how they look like in
comparison to what I've created in this
step right and then at the end of the
step you should always be able to do
manage cut run server node server Jazz
open it up in your browser and then you
should see something okay so I really
encourage anyone who wants to deal with
Django and react js2 just go through
this step-by-step and yeah hopefully be
hopefully be inspired that this should
actually works and it's actually
relatively easy to set up you don't need
to change your Django deployment process
and you can step-by-step start replacing
old stuff on your website with fancy
react components there may be one
example that I just deployed two days
ago so this is our old django website
and we are selling whiskey here for
example if you have a lot of cash i
basically replace the whole filters and
shopping grid here so because i wanted
this to be real time and everything so
now i can click add a filter and it
reloads immediately and shows me the
result immediately okay this way it's
not a good example let's go to art or
for some Bank I can click at next page
and it just loads the next page right
without actually doing a page reload so
the browser is not reloading the page
it's just sending an API request to our
server and the server is sending back
something like the JSON string that we
just saw from the github API right so I
can filter for prices see and it always
changes immediately so it's pretty fast
to pre the re rendering of the react
complex react components it's extremely
fast and
this is so much different from jQuery
with jQuery when you got back the Ajax
response you still need to find the Dom
element that you need to remove or to
replace or to update in some way react
doesn't care about this all you care
about is updating your reducers right so
basically you are when you think about
your application you only think about a
data structure right you think about
what do I need to display to the user
and if it's just a data structure in
your reducers and then you write those
react components around the and they
have access to the reducers and they did
they display the correct values that's
all you do and you are no longer caring
about Dom manipulation at all you are
only caring about updating your reducers
that's all you didn't need to do and the
Dom needs knows how to update itself no
ok thanks for watching I guess